bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d' europe hebdo nous sommes à
bruxelles au parlement européen dans
cette émission
direction l'île de lampedusa quelques
semaines après ce terrible naufrage qui
a coûté la vie à plusieurs centaines de
personnes nous sommes retournés sur
place
recueillir la parole des habitants mais
d'abord l'actualité les partis
politiques sont en ordre de bataille
pour les prochaines européennes et
constitue leur liste non sans polémique
alors les parties se fichent t-il des
élections européennes c'est la question
de la fraude
le torchon brûle entre le parti
socialiste et fait militants la cause
les listes aux élections européennes
comme à son habitude le ps a fait preuve
de trésors d'ingéniosité pour constituer
ses listes
concilier les courants les partenaires
saupoudrer quelques éléphants avec en
prime un ministre en exercice qui a
prévenu qu'il ne siègerait pas et
laisserait gentiment sa place au suivant
côté militant ça grince on se paye notre
tête on se fiche du monde
bilan 31 % seulement de participation au
scrutin
un appel au boycott est un vote
suspendus sur la liste de la région sud
ouest
pendant ce temps à l'ump au tergiverse
et on fore les couteaux joseph daul
président du groupe conservateur au
parlement jette l'épongé et nadine
morano est déjà en campagne
mais d'autres ont veulent tous si la
place alors les parties se fichent chine
les européennes
et pour évoquer cette épineuse question
des listes aux européennes c'est
philippe ricard qui nous a rejoint
bonjour bonjour
philippe vous êtes journaliste au monde
on ne vous présente plus vous êtes
correspondant à bruxelles depuis 2003
alors vous voyez ça d'ici depuis
bruxelles est ce que c'est un mal
typiquement français de faire des listes
un petit peu n'importe comment en
ménageant les courants les éléphants les
ministres qui veulent venir mais qui
finalement ne siègeront pas est ce que
on trouve ça ailleurs c'est vrai que
c'est une caractéristique très française
je dis pas que ça existe par ailleurs
bien sûr que ça arrive de temps en temps
que ministre italien plus en fonction se
retrouvent eurodéputés ou espagnol c'est
peut-être moins le cas en allemagne où
les professionnels ou les eurodéputés
sont un peu des professionnels du
parlement européen et donc font carrière
au parlement européen certains sont là
depuis extrêmement longtemps noyautent
toutes les positions stratégiques etc et
en comparaison avec les députés français
les eurodéputés français sont souvent
d'un niveau un peu différent avec un
engagement moins sérieux et tout ça est
forcément liée à la façon dont les
listes effectivement sont sans
constituer et donc du coup c'est moins
d' influence de la france au parlement
européen ici j'imagine puisqu'il ya un
truc turn over continuelle c'est vrai
que c'est le risque c'est le risque et
c'est un risque qui est avéré d'année en
année de législature en législature le
parlement européen c'est une place forte
des allemands qui part par principe
toute façon j'aime beaucoup
sept 7 ans est enceinte c'est eux qui
ont plaidé pour sa création c'est eux
qui ont plaidé pour sa montée en
puissance au fil de réforme des traités
et martin schulz le président donc qui
est allemand et socialistes démocrates
joue aussi un petit peu des coudes pour
affirmer la position que séparément
martin schulz effectivement est un bon
un bon spécimen en fait de l'implication
d'un eurodéputé allemand ici à bruxelles
comme à strasbourg d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'allemands tiennent des positions
extrêmement forte au parlement européen
que ce soit au niveau politique mais
aussi dans l'administration derrière
celle qui ça qui fait finalement tourner
la machine
martin schulz en plus lui essaie de
profiter de cette présidence du
parlement européen pour se profiler et
être chef de file des candidats
socialistes pour pouvoir prétendre
ensuite à la présidence de la commission
il s'est déjà présenté en tant que
candidat en fait normal les socialistes
et démocrates européens
quand on voit en fait une tête de liste
chez les socialistes en france en
l'occurrence harlem désir et convoi
entre guillemets son taux de présence
ici au parlement
est-ce que ça fait pas grincer les dents
ce que c'est pas logique finalement
quand on se retrouve avec des taux de
participation en france sur ces
élections qui soient minable oui c'est
vrai que lm désir comme d'autres
socialistes ou comme d'autres viennent
pays sont pas forcément des gens
extrêmement assidu il ya quand même des
députés français qui sont beaucoup plus
sérieux qui sont sans doute moins connus
qui sont moins qu'ils sont moins
visibles mais qui font un certain
travail voire sortis des listes
effectivement alors je vais savoir s'ils
vont être maintenues sur les listes
certains
craignent d'être écartée après il ya
beaucoup de combinaisons et de combines
un peu dans les partis la messe n'est
pas dite
on voit bien que même chez les
socialistes ou les choses sont déjà
assez avancée parce que les socialistes
voulaient socialiste français voulait
écrire leur liste d'ici à la fin
novembre début décembre
même là il peut y avoir des surprises et
le retour peut-être dans d'anciens
d'anciens qui ont fait leurs preuves et
caetera et qui pourtant risques que vous
voulez nous dire c'est que même si les
les militants ont voté sur les listes je
pense notamment dans l'est catherine
trautmann qui normalement tête de liste
elle peut très bien se retrouver en fait
sorti dans quelques semaines par
quelqu'un qui viendrait prendre sa place
on va voir je sais pas si ça on est là
mais effectivement il ya ce genre de
risque et quand on voit à l'ump par
exemple on a donc joseph daul qui est le
président de l'as du parti populaire
européen qui a indiqué qu'ils ne
feraient plus campagne fin du moins
qu'ils ne se représenteraient plus
nadine morano a déjà fait acte de
candidature arnaud danjean qui est bien
connu ici au sein de ce parlement ce
qu'il est président d'une
sous-commission défense cette espèce de
guéguerre comme ça finalement comment
quelle est votre lecture de tout ça la
guéguerre elle a lieu d'abord parce que
effectivement leur retraite joseph daul
laisse une place vacante
elle a lieu aussi parce que en fait ce
sont un peu de vision de l'europe qui
s'affrontent à l'ump une campagne
peut-être très pro-européenne de la part
d'arnaud danjean probablement quelqu'un
proche de michel barnier
par ailleurs lui aussi
la putatif à présidence de la commission
européenne et puis nadine morano qui est
peut-être sur une île à une seconde
ligne un petit peu plus eurosceptiques
qui est peut-être la ligne qui monte en
fait à l'ump pour essayer de contrer la
montée du front national
donc derrière cette opposition il ya une
opposition entre deux lignes de tactique
pour l'attenté droite quoi guerre des
droites pour savoir comment réagir au
mieux à la montée des extrêmes d extrême
droite en france
et bien justement sur cette question de
l'extrême droite marine le pen essaye de
créer une force supranationale elle a
été à la rencontre de son homologue
d'extrême droite geert wilders parti de
la liberté aux pays bas on l'écouté
le temps où les mouvements patriotes
étaient divisés était impressionné
peut-être même parfois terrorisée par la
diabolisation et l'inter diabolisation
ce temps est terminé
nous allons les party patriots qui avons
des points communs essentiels encore une
fois dans le combat que nous menons
contre l'union européenne nous allons
mettre nos forces en commun et nous
espérons pouvoir constituer une force
commune
après les élections européennes
donc là on se retrouve avec marine le
pen qui va voir ce parti d'extrême
droite aux pays-bas et qui essaye de
mettre en place une force européenne
est ce que finalement ils peuvent y
arriver alors marine le pen est bien
parti pour y arriver
l'enjeu pour elle c'est de savoir si
cette alliance en fait des extrêmes
droites européennes lui permettra de
constituer après le scrutin
un groupe parlementaire dans l'hémicycle
de strasbourg l'instant ils sont en
inscrire pour l'instauration d'un nasri
n'ont pas été en mesure ensuite à
différentes divisions pied comme souvent
des partis nationalistes donc s'unir à
d'autres forces européennes c'est pas
tellement dans l'eure dans leur dna on
va dire dans leur adn
mais là où elle parle de parti patriote
c'est ça qui est intéressant mais malgré
tout elle essaie de lancer aussi une
dynamique pour pouvoir être en mesure
d'établir ce groupe sachant que cette
fois ci elle a de fortes chances d'y
arriver
parce que là des partenaires potentiels
dans différents pays
et puis parce que tous les sondages
donnent l'extrême droite plutôt montant
dans différents pays notamment en france
il est bien possible qu'en france au
front national soit la première force
politique du pays européens donc c'est
quand même ça fait un choc un but de
bruxelles vu des capitales européennes
ça fera certainement un grand choc en
fait pour les européens de voir que le
front national est dans cette position
en france on en est pas encore là mais
c'est un petit peu se le dise les
sondages actuellement pareil au royaume
uni y occupe deux parties nigel farage
s'était déjà aux députés mais promis à
un brillant avenir électoral pour les
européennes
et là on sent très bien que les partis
traditionnels la gauche et la droite
sont très désemparé par rapport à
l'europe le premier ministre david
cameron au royaume uni sait plus comment
reprendre le contrôle du débat sur
l'europe à cause de la pression de yuki
ce qui se passe chez nos finalement
aussi
de façon beaucoup plus forte encore au
royaume uni puisque chez nous
effectivement le front national pèse sur
la ligne européenne des partis de droite
et de gauche mais il pèse pas encore
tant que ça sur la politique menée par
le chef de l'état françois hollande
vis-à-vis de l'europe
finalement la france garde un certain
engagement européen il est plus affaibli
par ses propres difficultés internes le
chômage la crise etc
françois hollande est pas toujours pris
au sérieux au niveau européen notamment
en allemagne parce qu'il sait pas
forcément les réformes nécessaires pour
remettre le pays à flot mais que
maintenant écarté européenne acea ses
pouces mais ce n'est pas encore le front
national effectivement qui fixe la ligne
merci philippe ricard d'avoir évoqué ces
questions avec nous on continue avant de
retrouver nos invités du débat direction
lampedusa nous avons voulu retourner sur
l'île quelques semaines après ce
terrible naufrage qui a fait plusieurs
centaines de morts recueillir la parole
de ses habitants c'est un reportage de
jérôme rabier
oui
planté face à la mer trois cent soixante
six arbres pour ne jamais oublier ce qui
est arrivé à 600 mètres des côtes de
lampedusa le 3 octobre dernier un drame
de l'immigration comme cette île d'à
peine 20 kilomètres carrés plus proche
de la tunisie que de la sicile ans vit
depuis 20 ans
ici l'arrivée où la mort de migrants
fait partie du quotidien
vito fiorino était en mer cette nuit là
quand avec des amis il a été réveillé
par des cris et franquin aurait fait
appel quand ou mal les personnes on
apercevait une marée humaine à perte de
vue
j'ai encore des frissons quand je
repense à cette image
ces personnes hurlait est les gîtes et
les bras en l'air on en a remonté de
plus possible sur une planète
et quand on est rentré au port qu'on les
a sortis sur le quai on nous a dit qu'on
avait sauvé 47 décidés à réagir
l'europe dépêche sur place le président
de la commission européenne josé manuel
barosso avant le sommet européen du 25
octobre qui doit aborder la politique
migratoire de lieux
mais à part mettre à juin prochain les
discussions après les élections
européennes
rien n'est décidé rien n'a donc changé
pour lampedusa et ses 6000 habitants qui
continuent de vivre au milieu des
vestiges de ces traversées périlleuses
nous sommes ici au cimetière de bateaux
situés en plein centre ville
c'est là que les bateaux d'émigrants
sont mis après leur arrivée au port ils
sont jetés ici nous sommes en plein
centre-ville juste à côté du stade de
foot à 100 mètres de la mairie
c'est ça la réalité de lampedusa c'est
ce que les habitants vivent tous les
jours
les images parlent d'elles même nom
c'est un spectacle désolant
on voit souvent des migrants venir
fouiller la à la recherche d'objets
perdus mais il n'y a rien à sauver ici
même pas le bois n'est pas le sentiment
d'abandon et vivace nous ne nous sentons
pas italien voilà la réponse des landes
pedu siens qu'il affiche sur les murs de
la ville dépourvue d'hôpital ou encore
de tout à l'égout lille et sous-équipées
l'europe est elle aussi accusée de ne
rien faire pour ce territoire qu'il ne
vit que de la pêche et du tourisme
seule avancée depuis la catastrophe
l'italie a décidé de renforcer sa
surveillance en méditerranée
les bateaux d'émigrants sont désormais
systématiquement secourus même loin des
côtes italiennes
ce sont les garde-côtes de lampedusa qui
en sont chargés sept navires dont 4
d'intervention rapide et 75 hommes sous
ses ordres
voilà ce dont dispose le commandant
canaris les pour mener à bien cette
mission sont des unités navales
construite avec des fonds européens et
notre programme fait aussi partie d'un
projet européen
ferradj et ap à l'heure où je vous parle
nous avons effectué plusieurs centaines
d'opérations de secours et rien que pour
cette année et nous avons sauvé plus de
13000 personnes par terre une fois sauvé
direction le centre de rétention de
l'île prévu pour accueillir 250
personnes alors qu'ils sont parfois plus
de 1000 combien de temps resteront-ils
ici
la loi prévoit 72 heures mais en réalité
cela dépend de la situation dans les
autres centres en italie
le problème principal c'est d'organiser
le transfert rapide de ces migrants vers
d'autres centres comme la loi l'imposé
on devrait les transporter quasi
immédiatement vers la sicile afin
d'éviter les problèmes sanitaires sans
problème ça l'autre il ne restait pas
des semaines comme c'est parfois le cas
lampedusa pourrait faire face sans
conséquences sur l'économie locale sur
la vie de la population
on pourrait même être fiers de sauver
ces vies humaines un espoir partagé par
la maire de la ville qui a été plaidé à
bruxelles pour un véritable changement
de politique européenne en matière
d'immigration
car selon les règles actuelles le pays
d'arrivée doit gérer seules les demandes
de droit d'asile des immigrés l'italie
comme d'autres pays du sud réclament une
solidarité plus importante
le futur de lampedusa peu changé s'ils
changent les politiques d'asile et si on
change les politiques d'accueil
s'il en p2a et respect
c'est dans sa mission de sauver des gens
et n'est plus seulement considérée comme
une prison au milieu de la méditerranée
et c'est bellsolà mme pedneault et s'il
en p2a sort enfin de sa marginalité
on aura alors la possibilité de créer
une vraie politique de cohésion sociale
et d'intégration pour améliorer la vie
des habitants
un rêve entre les mains des dirigeants
européens
pas pressé de parler d'immigration avant
les élections européennes de mai
prochain
les drames en méditerranée risquent
pourtant encore de tourmenter leur
conscience si rien n'est fait
et voilà pour ce reportage touchant à
lampedusa de jérôme rabier et pour en
parler sur ce plateau c'est carmen
romero lópez qui nous a rejoint bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
espagnol du groupe socialiste et
démocrate vous êtes de séville et jean
pierre audy président de la gueule
délégation française du parti populaire
européen
merci d'être avec nous quand vous voyez
un petit peu ces images de migrants de
cimetière de bateaux d'une ville et
d'habitants qui se sentent abandonnés
vous avez un petit peu le problème vous
dans le sud de l'espagne madame les
députés est ce que vous diriez que
l'europe a abandonné lampedusa écoutez
ce problème c'est pas à un nouveau
problème parce que nous vivons ce
problème depuis les années 80 en espagne
on a reçu beaucoup du naufrage dans le
sud qui venait de des marocains du
sénégal de mauritanie est bon et c'était
des naufrages et venait par dizaines
mais maintenant la broussaille vaines
ils viennent par centaines ça c'est ça
c'est terrible certaines catastrophes et
c'est pas la première fois parce que non
il a baigné la première catastrophe de
l'an perdu ça a été avec les techniciens
et bon c'est vrai que la commission
européenne
un art bien fait mais même après la
première catastrophe de lampedusa là
même la commission européenne n'a pas
réagi et non plus parce que l'italie et
la france n'ont pas arrivé à se mettre
d'accord parce que ça existait une
directive de protection temporaire et
alors on n'a pas respecté la loi et l
arrivée des tunisiens et le fait que à
l'époque le président du conseil avait
dit puisque personne ne veut nous aider
puisqu'on n'est pas solidaire j'ouvre
les frontières et je laisse tout le
monde passait et à l'époque d'ailleurs
on avait rétabli des contrôles à la
frontière jean pierre audy en france
pour éviter donc ces passages de
tunisiens les états membres peuvent
rétablir en vérité on a bien senti les
choses venir puisque dès 2008 sous
présidence française
c'était l'époque brice hortefeux était
ministre de l'immigration il ya un pacte
européen de l'asile et des migrations
qui a été adoptée par les gouvernements
et les chefs d'état et donc ce pacte que
nous mettons en oeuvre d'ailleurs
actuellement dans la législation avec le
vote de juin dernier prévoit
l'immigration choisie prévoit des règles
communes d'asile aujourd'hui ce qui est
enfin ce qui était absurde c'est que
quelqu'un qui de mai dans le demander
l'asile avait des règles différentes en
suède en france en allemagne
aujourd'hui il y aura les mêmes règles
alors il ya eu un élément nouveau c'est
toutes les révolutions le printemps
arabe
plus les les événements en syrie qui
amène ces personnes à tout prix à
vouloir venir sur le territoire européen
donc il faut un dialogue politique avec
les états qui sont les est à l'origine
de c2c de ces flux il faut que l'europe
se protège parce que nous avons une
période extrêmement difficile entre
cette construction européenne
ce moment deux de ces révolutions arabes
et puis le futur où nous devons avoir
des règles d'immigration choisie et des
règles d'asile extrêmement précise et
surtout poursuivre les passeurs quel est
le reportage médiatique qui indique les
suites qui ont été données
sur le plan pénal de ces criminels qui
commercialise les passagers qui font
prendre des risques et qui aboutissent
aux tragédies auquel nous assistons
alors c'est un autre problème que le
trafic qui s'organisent en fait autour
de ces passages toutefois vous parler de
la politique d'asile
ça fait longtemps que les pays du sud de
l'europe espagne y compris italie grèce
malte chypre demande en fait à ce que la
politique d'asile permettent de un petit
peu ouvrir tout ça sert que le règlement
aujourd'hui c'est le premier pays
arrivée doit gérer la demande et on
demande plus de solidarité à ce jour les
pays du nord refusé un petit peu une
fracture ça se passe écoutez on n'a rien
fait on dit c'est le trafic de des
gentils qui inquiète de wiki commerçants
avec avec les migrants mais on n'a rien
fait parce que on peut le sourire ça et
on veut on peut faire la recherche entre
la police de l'europe et la police des
pays qui viennent du sud
on peut faire des équipes coin gens
quand je conçois jouant bien
alors on peut faire ça mais on dit c'est
le moment c'est le problème du trafic
des données qui manque de coopération
selon votre l'un sur bien sûr il n'ya
pas tendre des réseaux on peut savoir
parfaitement où sont les schémas qui
prennent les trafiquants alors on n'a
rien fait donc c'est gouffran vous dis
là on leur dit de jours c'est le premier
veut pas régler le problème et est en
cours il y a comme un comme il l'a dit
le règlement dublin
mais le pp n'a pas jamais été reconnus
européen le parti populaire européen n'a
pas été d'accord à résoudre les
problèmes les problèmes de règlement des
blank et la qos de 10 problème c'est les
pays du sud qui doivent assumer les
mygales effectivement le règlement de
dublin ii c'est celui qui gère le droit
d'asile
devait être réformé il est toujours
coincé personne ne veut le changer pour
ça si je peux me permettre pour
clarifier les choses parce que j'entends
votre conversation ne confondons pas
l'asile et l'immigration je vous en prie
l'asile en france ces 20 mille demandes
par an donc et au niveau de l'union
européenne ces trois cent mille par an
l'asile est une étole d'une disposition
sur des personnes qui sont poursuivies
dans leur état qui risque la peine de
mort et qui demandent l'asile
bon nous sommes confrontés à des peines
de migration et d'asile quand vous
parlez de syriens d'erythréens de ce
malien ces pays sont en proie à des
guerres civiles
il ya un problème aussi de droit d'asile
oui mais il ya eu un problème de droit
d'asile n'en fallait les uns des
problèmes qu'aucun sont montés ccc
l'émigration économique pour lequel il
faut absolument que l'union européenne
ait des règles en relation avec les
capacités d'absorption et les nécessités
du marché du travail de l'union
européenne est donc temps que les
conditions de sécurité de protection de
l'union européenne en termes
d'immigration choisie ne seront pas
respectées il est clair que le groupe du
parti populaire européen ne s'assurait
ne s'associera pas à des appels d'air
qui sont extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'à ce moment là vous avez les gens
viendront puisque ils seront accueillis
il faut absolument que l'union
européenne se protège et sur la question
de manama
comment est ce que vous pourriez un
moment coopérer avec les pays du sud
pour éviter en fait ne serait-ce que ces
trafics
mais ça c'est pas en prendre deux
parlementaires se reprennent de
gouvernement ce sont les gouvernements
donc d etat en coopération avec europol
eurojust avec les magistrats en
coopération avec ces états et les forces
de police pour arrêter ces trafiquants
lorsqu'il y a eu la tragédie des
journalistes assassinés
on a mis en oeuvre toutes les conditions
pour que les coupables soient traduits
en justice
donc là ce sont des drames qui
mériterait effectivement je suis
parfaitement d'accord et carmen une
coopération policière et judiciaire et
de justice qu'ils soient exemplaires
chaque pays ne peut pas l'italie ne peut
pas le problème de l'emploi
et c'est vrai ce qui est dit et madame
bonino ils font une opération militaire
comme on l'a fait pour l'opération des
pirates en somalie
il faut une opération comme l'opération
atalante à l'union européen la
commission européenne doit faire doit
mettre d'accord tous les pays de
l'europe pour faire une opération qui
qui fuit et parce que c'était
catastrophe doit finir
et si la première chose c'est une
opération militaire on doit le faire
pour éviter le naufrage
pour éviter le naufrage c'est la
première chose éviter le naufrage
après c'est vrai que la coopération
bilatérale et la coopération nous vers
les pays tiers
c'est tout à fait indispensable nous
avons fait en espagne des patrouilles
conjointes entre l'espagne et le maroc
et on à résoudre le problème alors l
italie doit le faire même la france
mais black death mais il faut bien sûr
une coopération bilatérale mais il faut
aussi un rôle de l'europe plus fort
alors justement le rôle de l'europe plus
fort
vous avez reçu il ya quelques semaines
la maire de lampedusa que l'on a vu dans
ce reportage
et elle avait une question à vous poser
on les écoute
pourquoi les gens ont besoin de perdre
leur vie en mer après un long voyage
pour obtenir le droit d'asile à laâyoune
alors pourquoi est ce qu'on ne mettrait
pas en place finalement une politique de
visas plus ouvertes ou parler
d'immigration choisie qui permettrait à
ces demandeurs d'asile devenir plus
facilement en europe plutôt que d'avoir
à tenter une traversée où ils vont
perdre la vie bien sûr je verrais bien
comme il l'a dit distingué en train de
demande d'asile elle émigre 1
mais bien sûr mais ce qui arrive c'est
que tout le monde qui vient pour la
protection internationale et pour le
droit d'asile
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de restrictions
vous fait très élevé vous voyez dans
l'île de malte même dans l'italie dans
la grèce
des centaines des milliers de gens qui
demandent l'asile ils ne l'ont pas ils
n'ont pas la possibilité même de la
protection internationale
alors c'est pas possible ça c'est vrai
que les pays du nord donne plus d'acides
quel pays d'ici ça c'est le problème des
pays décident mais les pays du sud ne
veulent pas donner l'asile parce qu'il
pose un problème à l'europe
alors il faut engager sa démo je me suis
rendu à malte j'ai visité les les
les camps de rétention vous avez là
beaucoup de personnes qui sous couvert
de faire de la migration économique
prétendent demander l'asile parce que
peut-être dans leur état d'origine
ils sont poursuivis pour quelques délits
et donc ils veulent fuir et des
conditions économiques qui sont
extrêmement précaires pour elle ça je
peux le comprendre mais nous avons aussi
nos peuples nous a protégés de l'union
européenne on peut pas résoudre tous les
problèmes d'ankara lité il faut le faire
par des accords de politique de
voisinage entre l'union européenne et
les états du sud
nous devons nous nous avons un devoir
politique et morale d'accompagner c'est
révolutions arabes
c'est une joie que de chasser les
dictateurs et donc il y à des situations
difficiles mais j'insiste sur la
distinction entre l'asile et
l'immigration est aujourd'hui beaucoup
de ces personnes sous prétexte de
demander l'asile en vérité ce sont des
migrations économiques et ça on peut
après tout vous
il ya les cerner la migration économique
ne peut pas être espacés en of ages même
s'ils sont dénigrés l'attaqué quand même
un peu aux valeurs de l'europe
enfin jacques delors notamment avait dit
là quand on voit ces naufrages et ses
corps en fait sur les plages de
lampedusa c'est l'europe qui s'assoient
sur ses valeurs est-ce que je m'excuse
mais cette droit européen n'est pas con
passif je m'excuse n'est pas con passif
parce que on peut pas parler toujours
des délinquants il ya un pourcentage et
répété ils sont pas des landes à la
majorité la plupart peut-être rien 1%
mais la droite toujours paru des
délinquants des trafiquants et tous à
écouter c'est pas ça il faudra t il faut
gérer bien la question il ya un manque
d'humanité dans la gestion des crises et
audi quand on voit les conditions dans
les centres de rétention quand on voit
non mais j'ai visité les choses sont
extrêmement extrêmement difficile il
faut les régler
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord sur
l'opération c'est le mot militaire qui
me choque un peu mais il faut il faut
conduire des opérations des opérations
de de sûreté et de sécurité
conjointement entre les forces de
l'ordre européenne évidemment avec une
dimension européenne et les forces de
ces états pour poursuivre les
trafiquants est ensuite passé des
accords de coopération de migration pour
la migration économique bien sûr qu'ils
sont pas tous des délinquants mais
j'insiste vraiment sur sa distinction
entre asie les média écouté on ne vous
mettra pas d'accord pour cette émission
merci on attend d'avoir participé nous
continuerons ce débat puisque ça fera
partie à mon avis des débats qui vont
agiter les élections européennes
pour nous cette semaine s'est terminée
un rendez vous la semaine prochaine
bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
on